liszt alexis paulhan
bonsoir alexis est ce qu'au plan
sanitaire cette décision vous semble
justifiée
aucune non non mais ça fait longtemps
que cette gestion de crise n'a rien de
sanitaires là rappelez vous il ya
quelques mois l'idée véran disait qu'il
était hors de question d'avoir un pass
sanitaires pour les activités du
quotidien puis se passe et l'inter ne
devait pas être prolongé au-delà du 15
novembre rendez vous compte et voilà un
porte parole qui vient disons que le
gouvernement demande au conseil d'état
de prolonger se passe jusqu'à l'été 2022
parce que le parlement ne va pas siéger
aucune démocratie fonctionnelle
n'utilise cet outil sur cette durée là
c'est proprement scandaleux tous les
pays européens qui ont eu recours au
passé militaire ont arrêté au bout de
quelques mois seulement quelques
semaines même parfois le japon vient
d'arrêter c'est le cas de la norvège de
la suède du danemark
en france on a l'impression qu'on vit
sous un état de ce n'est pas une
impression d'ailleurs ça fait 18 mois
plus de 18 mois qu'on va être en état
d'urgence permanent avec un président
qui fait tout sous le sceau du secret
défense en conseil de défense et le
parlement n'y trouve rien à redire ou du
moins pas assez et là en plus voilà que
nous rentrons dans une phase de campagne
présidentielle où le parlement ne va pas
siéger c'est proprement scandaleux on a
mis tout simplement en pause la
démocratie dans ce pays et ça ne semble
pas choqué la majorité de nos
concitoyens c'est extrêmement inquiétant
parce que ce recul des libertés il peut
être pérenne si on n'y prend garde et le
conseil d'état comme le conseil
constitutionnel ont déjà donné beaucoup
trop de latitude au gouvernement pour
faire à peu près n'importe quoi avec des
lois d'exception qui n'en valent pas la
peine encore une fois se passe sanitaire
n'a rien de sanitaires il est là pour
diviser les français si la vaccination
fonctionne et c'est soi-disant le cas
alors il ne doit plus être en vigueur
sur sa prolongation le parlement l'a
quand même se prononcer un pied le
gouvernement dit aussi vouloir maintenir
la possibilité de recourir à cette
mesure ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il le
fera nécessairement non évidemment
l'idée c'est de dire on garde cette
mesure comme une mesure du quotidien une
des porte parole dans marque madame
jeanne tête disait oui se passe il
devrait d'ailleurs rentrer dans la vie
quotidienne des français comme le permis
de conduire comme le carnet de
vaccination des enfants n'ont
certainement pas c'est une mesure
exceptionnelle
sous un état d'urgence sanitaire il ne
faut pas que ce pass sanitaire
deviennent la norme or ce que veut faire
le gouvernement s'est ancrée dans
l'imaginaire des français le fait que ce
pass sanitaire 1 il est utile et 2 eh
bien il va être là pour à peu près
toujours parce que le virus il est là
pour à peu près toujours également c'est
n'importe quoi et j'espère j'espère
qu'il y aura un sursaut démocratique au
parlement et que enfin on va voir une
opposition digne de ce nom pour dire
stop ça suffit ce gouvernement fait
beaucoup trop de mal aux lois de la
république au base même de notre
démocratie
ça ne peut pas continuer comme ça sous
prétexte qu'il y à une pandémie cette
pandémie elle est installée elle est là
tous les autres pays ont cessé l'état
d'urgence il est question d'un temps de
gérer avec une politique sanitaire une
politique de santé publique classique
somme toute un virus qui est maintenant
connue donc c'est proprement scandaleux
ce qui se passe et et de voir que les
modèles macron s'en sort et continue de
vouloir pousser toujours plus loin les
limites du contrôle social les limites
aussi des libertés des français sans
jamais se recevoir une fin de non
recevoir justement par les institutions
conseil d'état et le conseil
constitutionnel
c'est extrêmement inquiétant pour la
suite et notamment avec la campagne
présidentielle qui va s'ouvrir et quoi
les urnes seront conditionnée à
l'obtention d'un poste sanitaire qu'est
ce qui se profile une élection
uniquement par correspondance
voilà à peu près ce à quoi s'attendre
avec ses parleurs de la république en
marche qui reviennent sur leur parole à
quelques semaines d'intervalle donc
pourquoi leur faire confiance et
pourquoi croire que finalement après
l'été 2022 le pass disparaîtrait non on
voit bien qu'il ya une volonté de faire
du pass un outil de gestion sociale en
france et ça peu importe qu'il y ait un
virus ou non alors c'est en vue de ce
scrutin que le porte parole du
gouvernement met en avant la nécessité
de prendre ses précautions en amont
alors que les travaux du parlement
seront donc suspendus à la proche de la
présidentielle il ne pourrait donc pas
se prononcer en cas de flambées
épidémiques c'est un argument que vous
n'entendez pas non non parce que le
parlement peut être convoqué un si
jamais il y avait une flambée épidémique
ou un cas de force majeure donc c'est
totalement un argument fallacieux qui
est là pour essayer d'endormir
l'opinion publique en disant que ne vous
inquiétez pas on ne va pas y recourir
sait si jamais on devait et si jamais on
devait en avril tient pendant qu'on doit
voter il faudra pas sanitaires pour
voter or aujourd'hui je rappelle qu'il
ne faut pas de sanitaires pour entrer au
parlement que ce soit au sénat ou à
l'assemblée nationale et non par contre
si ils devaient falloir a passé une
terre pour entrer dans les bureaux de
vote ça ça pourrait rentrer dans la loi
et ça ne choquerait personne non je
crois que c'est extrêmement choquant
évidemment donc il faut être extrêmement
vigilant
je crois qu'il ya suffisamment de
lanceurs dallaire qui soit à la fois la
défenseure des droits mais aussi des
associations de défense des droits de
l'homme qui se rendent compte du danger
de ce pass sanitaire pérenne et déjà et
redisons-le et encore il n'est pas
tolérable que nous soyons en état
d'urgence sanitaire depuis autant de
mois 18 mois c'est du jamais vu en
réalité il n'y a aucune raison que ça
continue comme ça et que le conseil de
défense soit la norme pour que le
président de la république qui a été élu
gouverne de manière isolée sous le sceau
du secret défense en faisant à peu près
ce qu'il veut avec des lois d'exception
non je ne suis désolé que personne en
france n'a signé pour une démocratie
aussi abîmé et voilà c'était le regard
de monterey éditorialistes alexis poule
remercie beaucoup alexis merci